j'ai un coup de cœur un vrai coup de
cœur parmi tous les smartphones qui sont
sortis depuis le début de l'année 2023
j'étais un peu frustré cette année parce
que il y a quelques produits que
j'aurais aimé avoir que j'ai pas pu
avoir notamment le find x 6 pro qui
était mon coup de cœur l'année dernière
le finding 5 Pro de oppo donc lui bah
voilà oppo pas fini on l'aura pas c'est
dommage mais parmi tous les smartphones
1 a vraiment obtenu mon attention alors
je vous le donne à la fin mais pour
l'instant je dois vous dire ceux qui
m'ont énormément plu il y en a que j'ai
adoré qui est sorti il y a pas très
longtemps c'est celui-là c'est le
nothing phone tout le nothing faut tout
il est tout simplement extraordinaire
avec de plus belles finition une
meilleure expérience au niveau de l'os
no singuos 2.0 ce qui en fait un
smartphone totalement unique et qu'on
peut un petit peu comparer des fois à de
l'innovation qu'on trouve chez Apple
mais là sur Android ça c'était vraiment
gros coup de cœur pour votre smartphone
qui est sorti il y a pas longtemps et
aller jeter un coup de ma vidéo si vous
l'avez pas vu parce qu'il est top
deuxième smartphone qui m'a beaucoup plu
c'est le Asus le zenfone 10 non pas
qu'il est énormément d'innovation mais
surtout par un petit format ajuste signe
et persiste avec un petit format qui
tient dans la main compact en dessous de
6 pouces ça ça va ravir plusieurs
personnes j'aime beaucoup leur
propositions les finitions sont vraiment
top donc c'était aussi un de mes coups
de coeur dans ce début d'année même si
c'est pas le coup de cœur ultime et
d'ailleurs pour ça bien protégé votre
smartphone grâce au coffre de mon
partenaire rhinoshield rhinoshi Fabri
des coques pour énormément de smartphone
bien évidemment les iPhone les airpods
les Apple Watch et d'ailleurs en plus
sur même des bracelets pour Apple watch
qui sont super simples à venir mettre
extrêmement confortable et que je trouve
très joli ils ont également des
protections pour les iPad pour Samsung
avec tous les Galaxy S mais aussi les
galaxies a mais il y en a aussi pour
Xiaomi les derniers pixels Huawei du
Swan plus et bien plus encore vous avez
les coques de protection les solides
vous avez également les clients avec le
dos transparent mode et NX crashgard
vous pouvez venir changer les contours
les boutons bref on peut tout
personnaliser ils ont beaucoup de
collaboration avec Marvel One Piece
France rugby PSG Disney League of
Legends j'en passe et des meilleurs mais
vous pouvez également créer votre propre
coque avec vos photos très facilement et
la grosse nouveauté cet été c'est l'Aqua
stand qui est livré dans sa protection
rhinoshield c'est une gourde avec un
support maxaf ce qui fait que vous
pouvez venir poser votre iPhone très
facilement vous le prenez vous le posez
directement comme ça et vous pouvez
l'utiliser directement alors soit pour
regarder des films des séries très
facilement directement vous voyez ça
tient il y a absolument aucun problème
soit pour vous prendre en photo pour
créer des contenus des contenus
verticaux et TikTok des contenus
horizontaux avec Youtube bref on peut le
mettre comme on veut c'est pratique
c'est vachement bien mais ils ont
également des protections d'écran vers
trempé bref il y a un choix qui est très
large chez rhinoshield et profiter de 5
% de remise avec le code qui est en bas
dans la description donc pensez à dire
protéger votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions et merci à
rhinoshi d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
alors le couture ultime il aurait pu
être dans le smartphone que je vais vous
citer tout de suite mais il lui manque
un tout petit truc mais c'est vraiment
histoire de poils de quelque chose voyez
c'est le Honor Magic 5 Pro qui est un
excellent smartphone en photo il est
incroyable l'algorithme derrière qui est
fait par Honor il est juste top ici
l'écran est beau le smartphone est
magnifique il est super puissant c'est
vraiment un super coup de cœur que j'ai
eu en ce début d'année mais il y a toute
petite différence quoi c'est très
implicite par rapport à mon smartphone
coup de cœur ça joue vraiment à pas
grand chose on switch un petit peu la
catégorie on va sur une innovation que
j'ai AD chez Motorola cette année pour
dire que 2023 c'est vraiment le gros
retour de Motorola même s'ils sont
arrivés déjà l'année dernière l'année
d'avant en France en tout cas là ils ont
des gros Inno qui vont faire ça va
devenir un acteur beaucoup plus puissant
et beaucoup plus important Razer 48
ultra ils ont ressuscité enfin ils
continuent à ressusciter mais cette
fois-ci sur une copie qui est vraiment
cool vous savez le Razer qui se plie le
smartphone à clapet qu'on avait dans les
années 2000 et bien là il devient encore
plus sexy avec un plus grand écran
extérieur beaucoup plus pratique des
mini jeux on a trois six mini jeux plus
d'autres qui vont arriver j'adore la
copie de Motorola là-dessus je trouve
très cool ils ont super bien bossé au
niveau de ce smartphone et ça en fait un
de mes smartphones coup de coeur même si
je pense pas que ce soit aujourd'hui le
smartphone que tout à chacun va venir
acheter en tout cas ça montre la
puissance de la marque et la montée en
puissance de la marque alors autre
marque qui m'a vachement plus c'est
Xiaomi avec son 13 pro et le premier
gros smartphone haut de gamme en
partenariat avec les cas au niveau de la
photo c'est top il y a des choix un peu
bizarre au niveau du mode portrait
certains modes noir et blanc on aurait
voulu un peu autre chose mais bon ils
vont dans l'esprit Leica et ce Xiaomi 13
pro m'a énormément plu il lui man pas
grand chose mais bon c'est pas encore
mon coup de coeur alors il y a notre
smartphone qui m'a vachement plus dont
je vous ai déjà parlé c'est le rock
Phone 7 d'Asus on est dans un monde
totalement différent univers du gaming
c'est pas du tout la même chose mais
pour tous ceux et toutes celles qui
veulent un smartphone extrêmement
complet au niveau du gaming avec
beaucoup de performances avec une vraie
bonne expérience parce que si vous êtes
gamer et si vous voulez du gaming sur
smartphone et bien le gaming sur
smartphone c'est pas uniquement avoir un
smartphone puissant qui se refroidit et
qui cartonne c'est pas juste ça il faut
toute l'expérience au niveau des
commandes il faut une belle expérience
logicielle totalement adaptée à
l'univers du gaming et c'est là-dessus
quasius c'est extrêmement fort avec son
roadfun 7 je vous parlais de Motorola il
y a quelques instants mais ils sont
revenus super fort avec un concept fun
que je vous ai présenté au MWC à
Barcelone on connaît les smartphones qui
se plie qui vont du plus grand au plus
petit du plus petit au plus grand qu'on
est beaucoup de smartphones on connaît
également de leur roulable que je vous
avais déjà présenté chez oppo me
semble-t-il début 2021 et bien là on a
un format d'enroulable signé Motorola
qui pour l'instant n'est qu'un concept
l'idée de Motorola là-dessus c'est de et
lui c'est de montrer regarder les techno
qu'on a nous aussi on innove nous aussi
on sait faire des choses alors pour
autant on le retrouve pas sur le marché
aujourd'hui soyons clair je suis pas sûr
qu'il arrive mais moto persiste et signe
une fois de plus dans le fait de dire on
est un acteur majeur on a des produits
sérieux on maîtrisé techno il va falloir
compter sur nous dans les temps à venir
on verra ça on regardera ça un peu plus
tard il y en a eu plein d'autres des
smartphones puis dans le milieu de gamme
avec des techno qu'on connaissait déjà
un petit peu mais il y en a un qui m'a
vraiment tout particulièrement plu parce
qu'il a porté quelque chose de nouveau
ce qu'on attend d'un smartphone c'est
d'avoir de la performance c'est qu'il ne
chauffe pas c'est d'avoir une très bonne
batterie pour de l'endurance d'avoir les
dernières technologies au niveau de la
RAM au niveau du rhum qui lui permet de
gagner en autonomie de gagner également
en performance ce qu'on veut également
c'est un bel écran pour avoir de
l'immersion pour venir regarder du
contenu de qualité des films des séries
pour pas se laisser distraire si ce
n'est pas son smartphone soyons clair on
veut que les Noirs soient noir on veut
que les couleurs soient vivent saturées
mais pas trop on veut bref une bonne
dalle on veut en plus qu'il soit un
magnifique appareil photo pour
immortaliser tous nos souvenirs tout ce
que vous allez venir shooter avec votre
famille vos amis faire des vidéos les
partager sur les réseaux c'est ce qu'on
attend d'un smartphone et il y a un
smart en ce début d'année 2023 qui pour
ma coche toutes les cases et un peu
au-delà c'est celui là c'est le Galaxy
S23 ultra pourquoi parce qu'en fait le
Galaxy S23 ultra il vient cette année en
tout cas en Europe avec un processeur de
Qualcomm le stade dragon 8 GN2 avant
c'était les processeurs maison de
Samsung qui sont bien soyons clairs mais
qui ne vont pas aussi loin que ce que
propose quoi comme alors ça veut pas
dire que sur les générations suivantes
on aura des proches de Qualcom on aura
peut-être le retour d'exinos mais
aujourd'hui en 2023 si vous cherchez un
excellent smartphone vous pouvez aller
les yeux fermés sur le Galaxy S23 ultra
alors soyons clairs c'est facile gros ça
va se marrer qui coûte tellement cher
qu'il est fatalement le meilleur c'est
pas forcément vrai il y en a plein qui
sont très bons qui sont tout aussi cher
et qui vont pas aussi loin qu'il y a
vraiment fait la différence pour moi au
niveau de ce Galaxy S23 ultra c'est la
douceur qu'on va retrouver au niveau des
photos je trouve qu'il y a une ambiance
qui se dégage sur des photos de nuit sur
des photos de jour il y a une vraie
émotion est-ce qu'on cherche à
retransmettre au travers des photos d'un
smartphone c'est pas juste de dire
regardez c'est joli regardez c'est bien
maîtrisé aujourd'hui tous les
smartphones dans les haut de gamme
maîtrisent vidéo lumière les basses
lumières bien que des fois il y a
quelques petits détails mais tout comme
le findige 5 Pro a été mon coup de coeur
l'année dernière parce qu'il y avait une
douceur et qu'il a porté vraiment
quelque chose à l'image ce petit
supplément d'âme qu'on retrouvait
réellement et dernière avec le fanick 5
Pro et bien je le retrouve cette année
avec le Galaxy S23 ultra prouve qu'il
apporte quelque chose au niveau du rendu
de l'image il raconte une histoire il
transforme les photos et il vous emmène
plus loin dans tout ce qu'on peut
attendre de son smartphone il est
puissant performant il a une superbe
autonomie l'écran est incroyable les
photos sont juste dingues et super bien
stabilisé l'écosystème en plus de
Samsung se développe énormément je vous
ai présenté le Galaxy boob 3 ultra pour
bien faire communiquer vos appareils
très facilement et là je vous parle que
de PC à smartphone il y a bien
évidemment des écouteurs et ça va
beaucoup plus loin machine à laver four
hot TV ça on en parlera un peu plus tard
donc pensez à vous abonner mais voyez ce
produit là c'est pas juste un smartphone
c'est un compagnon de route qui va vous
aider à vivre de plus belles histoires
et à mieux les raconter c'est ça qui me
plaît d'ailleurs si vous avez loupé le
test de ce smartphone la vidéo est là
foncez la voir franchement vous allez
pas être déçu